I think in the interest of time we
should
start so um dear audience here in the
room dear online audience that's also
joining this event is being
streamed I warmly welcome us to our
conversation on science diplomacy
today and um science diplomacy it sounds
kind of uh easy I mean it's
understandable right what it is but I
think on like a Second Glance it's
probably much more to it than we think
and that we know of and um therefore uh
I'm very very happy that we've been able
to recruit this real disting
distinguished panel here with us
absolute experts on science diplomacy
and people who actually know what the
what science diplomacy is and are living
this every day and um yeah I'm hoping
for a very interesting Lively discussion
also with all of you in the
audience and um yeah I think well no
before we start sorry um I'm Lisa Von I
am the head of Bing science week I'll be
moderating um the panel and before we
start with the discussion discussion
on some housekeeping um topics so for
the online audience especially you can
also join the discussion we have a
slider um there so if you have any
questions please post them in slider and
we will relay those uh during the Q&A to
the panelists so that's it and now let's
start so who do we have here uh we have
a very distinguished panel um so a very
warm welcome first to science Senator Dr
inor thank you for being
here we have uh with me also vadm Nagant
truk I'm sorry if I pronouncing this
wrong nayuk sorry okay uh the third
Secretary of the uh Embassy of Ukraine
with
us we have hila Engelhart head of global
agenda and scientific Affairs of the
Embassy of
Israel
we also have Dr Andreas kosida the
executive director of the falling walls
foundation and last but not least vivana
plasil the CEO of the body bear
[Applause]
Berlin okay so as I uh already started
uh with um my introduction science
diplomacy uh the first thing I would
like to know is actually what is it
exactly and how is it being done what
does it actually mean in practice when
we talk about science diplomacy and this
is this this question I would like
direct first to our Embassy
representative so I know hila maybe you
would like to start how how do you do
science diplomacy in normal days we uh
connect uh between scientists and uh
between scientific organizations and we
form the uh most of all the basic
Frameworks for their
cooperation
um we also Al
communicate uh what we are doing as a
country and we uh if needed H
clarify uh the basic values and the um
procedures we have in the government to
take care of issues that concern today
everybody in science like IP
Etc H but I have to say that science
diplomacy is uh not done H only in
embassies actually it's mostly done not
by embassies but by scientists
themselves
and I would like to um maybe use the
opportunity to uh first of
all
um dedicate maybe my appearance here
today h to a very dear person who on the
7th of October in the Hamas attack now
in Israel was kidnapped
abducted H by the Kamas and is still
held hostage in Gaza her name is Shana
haran and she was
actually with nine more members of her
family h on her Farm she's a
scientist ER and her specialty is
agriculture she um was researching for a
very long time H agricultural produce
and
seeds and um after many years she also
set up an NGO called Fair planet and
this NGO develops
seeds uh that uh um are of quality and
she has been working all throughout her
and many years as a scientist in Africa
with very poor communities H including
of course also Muslim communities
Christian communities and others to help
them uh raise and grow crops that are uh
more viable more resistant to uh um
weather and and disease of plants
and that uh um could bring them them
more Prosperity than some of the seeds
that have been used in the past that
weren't of such good
quality h two of the nine H have been
confirmed H murdered but the rest of
them are still held by the Hamas in Gaza
and uh I of course pray together with
the rest of my people and many friends
across the world for their safe return
people like her and other scientists who
just you know cooperate across
boundaries in Israel in Germany and in
many other countries are the real
ambassadors and real uh diplomats of
scientific
[Applause]
cooperation uh thank you Hil I'm really
um sorry it's really difficult to say
something after this um so um I just
give the the word to F nuk sorry um how
is what does science diploma seem to you
and how is it being lived um good
evening everybody um first of all I
fully agree that diplomats are not the
ones who are doing the main science
diplomacy it's scientists who are the
science
ambassadors uh I took this term
somewhere from your notes I guess uh and
uh today I think our Ukrainian main goal
is
to get our science ambassadors heard
today we have this window for
opportunity and we finally don't uh have
like false ambassadors claiming to
present Ukraine but actually just taking
our agenda like uh historians
who tried to rush
historians their voice which their voice
was much more heard than Ukrainian one
and it's not only about history it's
about every every science so that's it I
guess
first so scientist as the ambassadors of
science diplomacy um this is actually
something I had on my one of my
questions here and this is something for
U chora actually um because Berlin is
such a science diaspora there are so
many diasporas here there are so many
scientists from all over the world
working together is there something that
Bine
State doing for that like is is there
something um that's that's is it
something that Bine is also utilizing in
any way for U for uh furthering
International collaborations or like
what kind of Frameworks are there um is
this a topic at all all this
International people sorry sure it's a
topic uh we we are doing a lot I think
first um I wasit an Excellence cluster
last week um
contestations uh of the liberal script
and it's um um many people many
scientists um cooperate with people in
in many countries looking for these who
make these contestations against the
liberal scripts trying to to speak to
them to to cooperate also with these
people and um so that's a um really good
um um yes really good to to understand
conflicts and to understand um how um
these contestations work all over the
world also um in Berlin um on the other
hand we um have some money given to the
Einstein STI um um it's a little bit my
idea uh was it for um some years ago
um when scientists uh got under threat
in turkey and in other countries because
I knew uh the situation from Serbia and
from the Balkans and uh so we said okay
we want to be safe harbor for scientists
under threat from all over the world and
we um not we want not only to be safe
harbor but we want to to um give these
opportunities to um um make the research
here in Berlin uh when they have to
leave their countries and uh so we have
done a little bit um there are other
programs to to um for these people and
we try and because it's it's so
necessary that these research um doesn't
break that these um
competences uh we we don't lose these
competences and all these topics uh
scientists um make Mak research on
so um B is a safe harbor but also as a
way to enhance the actually the
Excellence research to bring all the
people together and give them
possibilities to work together and uh
this is now a question to Andrea so
falling wall Foundation is um has in its
mission to break the walls to um you
know any barriers that there to
scientific discovery and to promote
International corporations why does it
need an NGO to do that because following
following wall is the mothership of the
building science week and also the one
that pays my salary so it's it's another
a provocative question but well
everything needs somebody to take care
of things right before I start out I
want to um express my gratitude to to
yila to joining this panel and um as um
Louisa mentioned falling walls is
celebrating the day of the fall of the
Berlin wall but the 9th of November is
also the commemoration day of the
Ral and 85 years ago people started
smearing David stars on doors and this
is happening again in this city and
Jewish life is under attack and you have
the courage to be with us which is
fantastic but all of us we need to
remember our responsibility here in this
country in this very city of Berlin that
this kind of activity cannot stand and
anti-Semitism has no room among
civilized
people but coming coming back to to
convening and bringing people together
and um what the mission of falling walls
also includes obviously uh we are
dedicated to this International Spirit
to to to the idea to bring Visionaries
together from all cultures from all
religions from All Peoples uh to to join
forces and coming up with brilliant new
ideas how we can we shape this planet in
the future it's a very very high uh uh
stretched goal if we have to be really
strong we have to assemble over a
thousand thinkers no laurat CEOs uh
people from European union and other
governments um because once you have so
much brain power together and uh uh and
impulses from all different fields you
can come up with something great and we
as a people uh on this planet we need to
work together and not fight each other
among about some some some ideology but
we have to think together what can we do
um to take care of the Water Crisis to
to tackle climate change uh and to work
for a bright brilliant optimistic future
and one day flight to the stars together
um so after these ideas are kind of like
crystallized out how does science
diplomacy actually work uh me myself um
before I drifted into science management
I was a particle physicist so and um
when you join a lab like CERN or other
big
institutions um you have people from all
over the world from All Nations and
they're not like completely negligent of
their Heritage or their religion or
anything but there's a mutual respect
because you do something meaningful
together and if you do something
meaningful together you have to respect
the person you're doing it with and this
is the key to to how how the lab codes
bring peace because I'm forced to not
only talk with you about science but we
will talk about your kids we will talk
about your country we will talk about
your history and there leads to a lot of
understand standing and if I take it one
step further and I build a big machine
together or fly to the moon together all
the industries from all these different
um uh countries they will have to work
together too okay so it's not just lab
codes right it's everybody who
participates in some kind and it's now
imagine building like a big particle
accelerators there's components from all
over the world and all these engineers
and all these sales people or even uh
people very down in the in the in the
working rooms they they get in contact
with other people as well so I know it
always sounds a little cheap to say
let's talk to each other but uh it Still
Remains true and if science brings
people together brings good ideas and
brings the room to to make these
exchanges possible then science
diplomacy works and we as falling wall
try to contribute at least a little bit
to
that uh vivana um baddy bear has a
totally different approach for promoting
tolerance and Intercultural
understanding you work with symbols you
work with art um how does it work like
how is the body bear contributing to the
science diplomacy um well I think it's
not it seems to be very different but I
think the the common idea between
science and art and culture is that
different no matter no matter uh what
what your nationality what your religion
is you come together you you you bring A
New
Perspective and this this New
Perspective helps driving change maybe
changing your perception changing um
yeah neglecting also um maybe any any uh
Prejudice you you could have and what
you say I I totally agree with you that
um I think starting it it has to be a
there has to be a starting point and you
can you can use or science but also art
to work together to to um collaborate
and that brings um this this uh
interdisiplinary work brings people
together and brings new ideas and maybe
could also help to to bring yeah more
tolerance definitely but also peace in
the world because um you start yeah you
start working together and maybe the
only or where could be where where could
art May maybe add something differently
is that art has maybe and and culture
and maybe um especially now by the body
Bears they can evoke emotions and these
emotions help to to work together so I
think it's not so different it's it's
just that art and science uh should work
together a bit closer I think
yeah and that's why we have Arts and
Science Forum during the Berlin science
week um okay so that sounds all you know
it sounds all wonderful um so basically
what we need is more scientists in the
same room working together on one
project right and then everything is
solved
or now I not everybody is a scientist
not everybody can be a scientist but of
course we all profit from scientific
discoveries and advances but I'm just
wondering if that would be so easy just
put everybody working the same thing we
would have done that already so are
there any challenges or barriers that
you encounter in this bringing well just
even scientists together is there
anything there that's hindering it and
maybe maybe you have
um when you try to get all this um
programs on the way is it
difficult sure it is um but I'm I'm
thinking about if it's true that only
scientists were work together because um
um I'm an archaeologist and when
archaeologists go in the field they work
not only with other scientists but they
work in the field they work with many
people and I think it's not only
archaeologists do this um they um work
in the country they work with the people
they uh talk to them not only to
scientists but um they learn a lot about
um these communities and I think it's my
for example biologists or ecologists or
every scientist um who does work in in
foreign countries and cooperates with um
scientists from foreign countries um
also has is connected to people in these
countries and and learns a lot a lot and
so um I think it's it's um very
important to fund these um activities
and these cooperations but uh in the
first it's it's the universities it's
the institutions who decide where to
work and which topics to to u to make
the research on and we can fund it and
um we can um but it's not not uh it's
more um the federal ministers the
federals um who have to do um it to to
um um yes um overcome the borders um for
example of laws and and possibilities to
work
together can can can I add to that about
the challenges uh I I really liked your
explanation here and I want to maybe
highlight it from from a different from
a different angle um I I always see the
the very challenge is um each Nation or
in each municipality they have their
their resources their funding and if I
want to do something cross borders I I
need funding cross borders right so in
in in Jordan for example there's the
Sesame synchrotron a fantastic
opportunity from people from Arabic
States and and the state of Israel to
come together I think it's Jordan Turkey
bahin Cyprus Israel working together
even Iran even Iran and it's funded by
the UNESCO right so or partially funded
by UNESCO so what what we need to
consider is what kind of supranational
or International bodies could be
empowered to specifically call for
crossborder corporations right so
because obviously you need to keep your
your funding together the same goes for
the Federal Republic of Germany
everybody has a little bit for
international activities but it's always
really hard to actually do it because
you need to get all these different
governments on the same page and if the
governments don't really like each other
then there's no real room for science
diplomacy right so that that would be
something that I would suggest uh in the
future to to maybe think about ways to
to have a more International approach on
things maybe I can come in on this and
say that uh ER I connect to the fact
that uh there needs to be political will
on part of the governments for a cross
border cooperation to happen H not only
in terms of funding H for example in
Israel when scientists want to reach out
and work together with
jordanians and Egyptian scientists even
though we have peace agreements with
these countries for many years now H
it's very difficult to make this happen
because uh H the scientists on the
Jordanian and Egyptian side um will be
quite apprehensive about working with
Israelis in their societies as a whole H
this is not easily accepted to say the
least and uh plainly they sometimes fear
to do anything like that because uh they
might not be safe H then them and their
families this is very
unfortunate um and um it makes the uh
project of Sesame which is actually
heavily German H also H because the uh
Sesame synchotron came from hel
helmholtz I believe Berlin originally H
but um H but it really underlines the
importance of education and this cycle
that if you educ at people for tolerance
H they can actually take this step
forward which will then also create more
tolerance and it's a cycle and I want in
this um respect to mention the abam
Accords H which were a significant
sighten vend for us H in the Middle East
with the especially the United Arab
Emirates which has a very strong drive
and motivation to uh develop itself uh
scientifically it actually wants to
reach the moon as uh with taking this
metaphor that was used before me and uh
in this they really see the the value of
cooperating with Israel and one of the
things that are interesting that I heard
a couple of months ago about what
enabled the United Arab Arab Emirates to
take this first step of breaking the
non-n normalization circle of the Arab
countries with Israel was that they
previous to this step for at least one
year if not two who had a very deep
education campaign all across the board
through their media in their schools
they H were they did this whole program
about tolerance without even mentioning
Israel H they just did a program about
tolerance and educated people for
tolerance and this is crucial what we
see um today um what we understand is is
that H this is not about Israeli Arab or
any political conflict right this is
about people who want to construct a
society a viable Society a living one
much like the one here in Germany H in
vibrant Berlin much like the one in
Israel H and the other side is not H
Arabs or Israelis it's not Israelis or
Palestinians the other side are very
radical fundamentalist Islamic groups
that use terrorism like Isis like
Al-Qaeda like
Hamas to and attack the very foundations
of our societies so the the attack is
not against an army the attack is
against people who may be scientists
they may be artists they may be um NGO
uh people Innovation people ja plane
people dancing in the desert H and it it
aims at the very infrastructure of our
society and our values and and this is
this is I think what is important to
understand and connecting to H your
message which I was thankful for at the
beginning I want to also say it's so
important in Germany now and all over
the world for scientific institutions to
and for for academic institutions to h
stand up and have moral clarity about
this and guide young students H with a
moral campus to be able to distinguish
between the complex issues around this
and take a clear moral stand to protect
everyone everyone on the campuses
Israelis Jews Muslims Palestinians
everyone has to feel safe everyone has
to be able to participate in Israel we
have scient Israeli scientists who are
Jewish and Arab and Muslim and
Christians and they are all working
together it's not always easy but it's
always important and now is the time for
us to hear every leader of every
institution in their own institution
speaking up for tolerance speaking up
for H the safe uh the safe the safety of
all the people so that they can continue
working on the challenges Humanity has
today in climate in food security and
every issue physics chemistry
everything this this actually uh reminds
me thank you very much for this
statement uh it reminds me a bit of um
you know when we had uh it's totally
different situation but um this attack
on Democracy in many different ways
that's happening that we seeing um in
different places so it can be uh you
know like during the coover the the
whole uh anti vaccination movement um
threatening people who are wearing masks
or just basically just based on
misinformation
on sometimes maybe just Plains lack of
scientific literacy but also media
literacy U education I mean all this
it's it's not um it can take many forms
this attack on Democracy right so I'm
just wondering um because now in Ukraine
the the situation is a bit I mean I
don't want to compare in things but
there is a situation that's just as um
dramatic um there you don't have the
religious polarization or any of that so
do you also consider this being an
attack on Democracy like how would you
want to maybe add to this uh yes of
course it was attack on Democracy it was
attack on all spheres of our lives so
Russia destroyed uh some scientific
buildings many universities in Ukraine
and so on and so far cultural
institutions they are all aimed for
their missile attacks
uh 5,000 Ukrainian scientists left
Ukraine after 24th of February so they
created kind of scientific diaspora they
never wanted to
create uh we still hope we believe that
these people will return uh and
contribute to the recovery of
Ukraine um it was attack on democracy
and it was not only attack on Ukraine uh
and sometimes I guess uh you shall
be uh let it let me say uh you shall
always uh be aware that scientific
cooperation can lead you can be tricky
can lead you not there where you think
you are going to uh especially when
you're uh the part you are trying to
cooperate with has totally different
goals uh
so Russia and Germany they did cooperate
in many ways in scientific ways take for
example North stream I guess it was kind
of a masterpiece of scientific thought
uh but for Russia it was from the very
beginning just a weapon which it turned
to be after
all
um and uh my thought here is
just think who are you cooperating with
what aim you are uh what you aim you
have and be sure that the aim you have
is the aim the other side has when you
are cooperating within the Democratic
world everything will be
fine
[Applause]
okay so how do
yeah science uh can contribute to a
democratic World definitely not alone I
I was thinking maybe going to the topic
of science communication actually
because um you know science scientists
do cooperate that I mean we already
talked about that but this bringing
societies so it's not just education
it's also a matter of like how do you
actually bring this idea of that the
world like we think is desirable at
least is actually a good one everybody
should work on um do you have any ideas
or you know examples of initiatives that
may be doing just
that yeah does anybody else want to go
go ahead I can add ER let me give a a
phenomenal example you know ER I'm
sitting here as a representative of the
state of Israel in Germany all of my
grandparents were born in Germany they
all immigrated to Israel in the 1930s
because of the Nazi regime here and
ER and the Holocaust is such a tough
piece of history that Israel and Germany
holds together as a a collective trauma
for both of our
Nations H the trauma of the oppressor
and the trauma of the uh victim both
very very tough traumas and I think that
ER in the
Reconstruction of in the healing process
of both of our societies from this
terrible trauma that might take we don't
even know how many decades or hundreds
of
years H science has played such a
pivotal role in fact the scientific
relations between Israel and Germany
preceded The Diplomatic ones it was Max
plank then and The whitesman Institute
both beacons of excellence in research
uh with Noel Noel Nobel Prize winners
and and many really amazing research
going on H in in those centers in the
centers of Max Plank and in Israel
and
um the their ability to build programs
has really and then also for others to
follow in their steps today we have the
G Israel the German Israeli fund H that
funds research we have a Helm Hol has
office in Israel frown Hof has several
topical Platforms in Israel there is so
much excellent research that is being
conducted by scientists and researchers
from both countries working on it
together bilaterally that is a country
with country and also multilaterally in
the framework of the Horizon Europe uh
framework Pro research uh
program um and and so definitely I have
to say yes ER positive action is
possible it's necessary but it's also
possible and it's proven to be
effective H and again and I do apologize
these are such tough days for Israel and
I bring here examples that I know are
very tough but in Israel we had a
wonderful um Science educ Education H
researcher she started actually by just
being a teacher she's a CH IST she was a
chemist and uh she taught in high
schools in Israel and then she started
researching with the whitesman
Institute ER and her the topic of her
research was scientific education and
she was trying to develop new ways to
engage young people h in science H to
make it more accessible for them even
online and not only online her name was
Marcel FR kapon H she she lived for 40
years on kib in kibuts B and H on the
seven of October she was murdered but uh
look at the reaction of the H whitesman
Institute H she was a member of the uh
of an American H organization that is
like a global in um um a global
Organization for Science
Education and H they have a yearly
conference H this organization like many
actually in the US uh
H their reaction to what happened in
Israel H was let's
say h not clear enough I will put it
diplomatically and The whitesman
Institute decided that as a constructive
step what they are going to do is give a
yearly stipend for doctoral students to
come to the conference of this
body to finance people that are not
Israelis from other countries in the
world on the name of Marcel FR Kap and
to her memory and of another H science
educator that H was also murdered the
same day so you take the
the the challenge that we are challenged
with is to take H the reality that we
have even in the darkest moments and the
most difficult times and find a way to
move it to to work with this material
and move it towards constru RVE Positive
Directions and it doesn't matter where
you do it if you are working on the
Israeli
German H H healing process if you are
working on inside Israel as I said
between H Jews and Muslims in Israel if
you are working with Israel and other
countries in the Middle East and it
doesn't matter also the scale if you are
doing it with millions of
people like sh harand did in Africa or
if you are doing it with you know two
people or 10 people it's just important
to know that you are contributing to
making the future a better
place that's
beautiful so I'm I'm I'm very glad that
you you mentioned the the the first
visit of of or official visit of the of
the German science system after the
second world war in in Israel and it was
1959 as you as you explained it was
members from the max Blanc
society that visited Israel and I find
it always when I he to hear the story I
find it extremely hard to imagine the
feeling of these ambassadors there was
no diplomatic relations as as you said
it it was the first time officially that
somebody from Germany after this
Holocaust came to
Israel I myself I cannot put myself
mentally in this in this perspective
right I mean they were most certainly
not greeted very nicely by everyone I'm
pretty sure sure there was a lot of
people booing them and uh it may be even
worse uh but look what happened and um I
want to come back to my point that I
made earlier there was some meaningful
interaction these people sat down
together they realized okay we have this
huge load of historic uh uh guilt and
and and horrible things there's a lot of
wounds that did not heal yet but we have
an agenda we have a couple of things
that we might do together to the greater
good okay so they had a a meaning ful
interaction they came together or to
make it even more bluntly if you all
consider where do you meet your friends
or where did you meet your girlfriend or
your husband or something like that
every once in a while it's the
University or it was even the school or
maybe it's even more mundane than that
some kind of club or choir or wherever
right because there you have a forum
there you have time to do something
meaningful with other people thus
getting to know them and I again I think
this is the very core of science
diplomacy and why it works so well
because in science basically well not
every time but a lot of uh occasions
where scientist me there something
meaningful will come about right so
that's why science diplomacy might be a
very efficient form and maybe a little
bit more um let's say structured or gold
driven than than other let's say just
more touristy exchange events but I
think at the very core uh as soon as
smart people who are willing working
together on something that's interesting
for both sides good things will come
from it and that's science diplomacy
that's what we should push
for um I would like to add something um
of of course I'm not a scientist um but
I'm here for for Buddy bin for our
initiative and maybe I would like to add
something because you were talking about
science communication I think um
communication starts earlier than for
for children also um already maybe it's
not called or we cannot call it science
then but um I think it's very important
to to Really
um yeah start earlier in in in the in
the child days where um where you can
really try to to to fight against
Prejudice and that's maybe I can bring
the idea of of of the United uh body
Bears which is practically um
150 beers standing
each of each of them representing one
country and each of them um yeah was
painted by an artist of that respective
country and uh so the idea or the
message is and I think this is important
for all of us so basically we are
everyone looks differently but at the
end we are all the same and we stand
together and we stand for yeah a lighter
vision of of a peaceful world and I
think it's I mean it's so it's so
difficult in these days because we have
so many conflicts all over the world and
we have here uh yeah um the Ukrainian
and the israelian um yeah
representatives and we are so I mean we
we I cannot say or we all are so sorry
and um we are very grateful that you
came here but I think even then we need
I mean we need to have some hope and we
need to be positive also and that's why
I think let's start let's start to work
on yeah for our children and our for our
future to really help um understanding
each other and yeah stand for for uh
tolerance and let's really start already
as soon as possible and not and not only
once we are adult and maybe are full of
prejudices
yeah that's the scrapping and we have so
many meaningful things to do I mean the
climate crisis the all kinds of
crisises um I would like to open the
floor to the public so um are there any
questions from the
audience
here hello uh thank you every everyone
um I'm Vijay I'm one of the journalist
uh fellows of uh Berlin science week so
I have the question to the whole panel
but specifically to the delegates from
the embassies so um universities in
Israel Tel Aviv University or wisan
Institute as you mentioned it's known
for international collaborations and we
have seen after the Russian um attack on
Ukraine universities in Ukraine and
other European countries they came came
together in terms of
collaboration but we also learn that um
there is um sight takak mentality even
among scientists you know there was a
Twitter row when a professor uh
apparently sounded like sympathizing
with uh the Hamas and he was being
cornered or targeted so when we are
talking about science diplomacy I think
we also have to think about scientists
as human beings ourselves and we are
prone to error or bias so when
scientists take sides for example when
scientists um run conference they bar
scientists from Russia even though they
are against the attack on Ukraine they
are barred from registration so how does
science diplomacy work in you know such
scenarios where there is is a
saking
mentality uh well I don't think that
science as any other sphere of life is a
political everything is political our
days and you need to take sight you do
science like not for nothing you do it
for something if you do it for a world
to be a better place just do it for all
to be a better place with people who do
it for a world to be a better place I
guess taking sides is not
bad anybody else who has a different
opinion on the panel h i i i uh can can
relate to this in the sense that uh when
something happens that is a brutal
attack on the foundations that we are
lean leaning on you must take a stand
silence is not an option and I want to
connect this to H in answer to your
question to the importance of a um of
the leadership of the scientific
institutions when H there is a person
inside a s scientific institution that
is taking a
Side
ER in
um the it is up to the leadership of the
institution to Pro provide the moral
compass and the clarity of where the
boundaries are people H can of course
Express different views and it's very
important to really guard the fabric of
the relationships even when people have
different
opinions ER the heads of the scientific
institutions in Israel of the top ones
the Israeli science science
Foundation ER and and two
more actually sent a letter in the last
days to the heads of the scientific Comm
H commun communities organizations in
other places in the world including
Germany and in this letter one of the
things they
addressed ER is the importance of this
fabric inside Israel that I was
mentioning earlier the Muslims and Jews
and Arabs and and and H Israelis working
together in the This research field it's
very important for us to uh maintain uh
the possibility to all be as one and we
are one you know when we when the
attacks of the 7th of October happened
it's not only Jewish people who were
murdered people were murdered of
different nationalities who happened to
be there and also Arabs bedwin who were
there H even when they shouted out I'm
Arab and spoke in Arabic they were
equally murdered and kidnapped so H it's
it's there is a limit to what you can H
do and I think that in the case
uh of
a um at least of what of what is
happening today in the world H with
fundamentally fundamentalist Islam and
terrorism ER and you are more of an
expert on the Russian front than I am H
you can put a clear border to what is
what is permitted and what isn't but
definitely
there is a limit to even to freedom of
speech even to Freedom you know of
of to to the free flow of scientific
this is ideally this is an ideal we
should of course er um be H directing
ourselves towards but not blindly not
the freedom to lie not the freedom to
misinform not the freedom to incite
there has to be
a a limit that we set to protect our
democracy the de democracy has to
protect itself and the scientific world
the academic world has to defend itself
against forces that are trying to attack
it um but definitely I want to
say
ER at the end of the day the challenges
are H the this may interest the media
but these are not the main challenges uh
of a country under attack uh perhaps
this is the same for you for us now I
can say in the past weeks ER first of
all the in many of our International
students in the labs in Israel have left
Israel H some have still
stayed H our young scientists have been
recruited to the uh Army now to reserve
duty H schools have stopped operating
and are now only starting to operate and
only partially H because uh they need to
have protected spaces for the students
in case Rockets because the Rockets are
still falling and so H many of the labs
are to to different extents affected by
this depending on what who was in the
lab before but a lot of things stopped
and here again you need the leadership
for example ERC Europe decided to popone
by three weeks the deadlines of the
calls for proposal that's really it's
Kudos I mean h this they postpone it not
only for Israelis by the way they
postpone it for everyone but so that
also the Israelis could take part it's
important to take such steps there are
things that can be done to make sure
that these communities of scientists get
a chance and I think that every
scientist organization Institute and and
as individuals should be on the lookout
to see where they can include uh
researchers from Israel from Ukraine H
from the Academia from the industry in
their research today and make an active
effort to do so this would be a positive
thing one can do to counter terrorism
and to promise that uh this scientific
diplomacy goes on in the future even
while our peoples may be experiencing
challenges right now in the applications
Etc maybe I can can add to that I I
really like this different differentiate
view on on on the issues we're talking
about I mean me personally I I don't
like Benjamin Netanyahu I don't I like
his policies and I was rooting with the
people demonstrating a couple of months
ago because of the um of the political
reforms going on there but the question
whether I like Israel's policy yes or no
has no relation whatsoever
to the fact that me as a civilized human
being condemn this barbaric terroristic
attack I mean this is not a political
question right so but coming back to to
to your question I I think another
important aspect of of let's say
mobility of people via VI scientific
exchange um because numerous Studies
have shown and I think it's a common
common known fact that when I spend some
time in other countries and have some
meaning interaction with people from
other countries um the likeliness of me
myself being xenophobic or hate driven
or narrow-minded declines very fast
right so uh I spent a year of my studies
in in uh in the United States I was in
France I was in in the
UK I I I'm pretty sure that this helped
me uh to have like an open mind to other
cultures I was in the in the south of
Texas okay
these are not across the board very well
educated people with different ented
views on the world this is a pretty
rednecky area where I was but I learned
to understand these people where they're
from why they are voting for George W
bush and why they carry guns everywhere
I mean it's a their state of mind so
that does not mean that I necessarily
agree with everything they say but I was
able to like okay they think about it
like that okay they were settlers in the
west and they were in danger all the
time and they need to protect their land
that's why everybody can shoot things
and stuff like that and it's I I
understood the history and I understood
um why they're doing things I don't need
to dis I I don't need to agree with them
in all all areas but I have an
understanding and I think if we Foster
this kind of Mobility I really like this
um scholarship uh plans that you
presented here these are all little
things that can help
right one point more uh you mentioned
Russian scientists uh I guess issue
which shall be also mentioned is
responsibility so I guess uh if what
Russian scientists could do is
contribute to Ukrainian Victory uh there
are many ways from the very first days
many Ukrainian scientists engineers um
started to make drones for the army of
course not every science is about drones
but there is always the way and yeah
perhaps that's what they shall be doing
now
okay I guess your question got
answered do we have any more
questions um do we have any questions
from the no okay oh there is a question
over there
yeah so uh we are facing in the last
couple of years
um uh tendency that people believe
more oh that people believe more in fake
facts or alternative facts what could
scientific collaboration do to um face
that problem because there is more
disbelief in science and I mean the
Earth could be flat we don't know
what um yeah how could scientific
collaboration help the whole world to
get past that point and to get past uh a
not liberal
world who would like to maybe um sorry
can can I answer just like although I'm
not really supposed to answer any
questions but you know we at the berin
science week and it's funded by the
berin Senate so maybe that's one of the
ways just want to throw it in here but
uh yes sorry go
ahead I just thought that the very fake
uh fact fake fact no like fake Narrative
of the whole Russian war against Ukraine
is based on that Ukrainian Nation
doesn't exist and people in Russia do
believe this uh what could we do we
could of course promote uh first of all
we should win the war to make Russia
change to make it free to uh to make
their uh space for free SS for real
science because now today the main
scientist in Russia is called Putin who
just writes an article about the unit of
Ukrainian Russian and belarussian uh
Nations and then start the
War I think look at this place look at
this museum look at what they do to to
uh bring to the children the
um they the children can learn here a
lot about natural science they can learn
about climate change
can uh learn about um facts so maybe
they won't um won't believe uh um these
in the
future and um so that's a place that's a
place um where all this is done what we
need uh about communication of
science can I add so first of all thank
you for this question because I think
it's a very important issue I mean
there's 20 or 30% even of people who
don't really believe in science anymore
are a skeptic I don't know how this is
measured but it's not just a couple of
lunatics but quite quite a significant
number of people I think the the the
answer to this to this question is not
an easy one I think there's numerous
factors coming together one of which is
certainly um the the still not really
understood phenomena of of people
multiplying in social media um that have
an audience that's not really connect
connected to any kind of skill Authority
or any kind of background so somehow
people who have very obscure thoughts
gain a lot of
audience I I would love to see this
explored and scientifically analyzed but
I can tell you one thing what I'm sure
about how to how to tackle this I think
it's about a new approach to to science
in general as we see here in the science
we as we see in this beautiful Museum we
talked about it two days ago with the
director here in the first in the first
row you need to spark curiosity right
you have to do it in the schools you
have to do it continuously you have to
do it on all kinds of levels it's not
about reducing complexity or anything
like this science starts at a very very
basic level observing a bug as a little
child or looking in the sky and seeing
the clouds I mean these are the first
steps
towards seeing explaining understanding
all right this is basically science
everybody does it every day there's no
like red line now you have a PhD now you
do science no it's not as soon as you
start to hear or see something and have
some thoughts about it and talk to other
people and combine it then you doing did
you doing some some kind of scientific
or knowledge uh extraction from the
world so that means if we rethink our
efforts of science communication uh in a
way that is more centered around the
Curiosity or driving the Curiosity of
the audience listening to the questions
and then providing answers that would be
something in tendency I think at least
would would help in these matters and
that's why falling walls and with
heavily supported by by the mun
municipality and the state of Berlin is
doing this
here but it's a very important issue we
could do more you're right and uh from
an international perspective obviously
it's always very nice to to go to a
conference or a science fair or
something like that in other countries
and exchange strategies or ideas ah
you're doing it like this oh we have
this Bo who bring science and rivers and
other people from other countries come
say oh that's very interesting we could
do it as well and learn from each other
obviously that's that's always nice in
in an international scenario that's why
we're so happy that there are so many
International guests with falling walls
and here in this burland science week
that's why we're doing this in English
by the
way yeah just to say really H Berlin
science week is a wonderful event H I
personally bring my uh kids to uh H to
to the events to uh um try and encourage
them also to curiosity H also it's
already been said critical thinking
about this your sources is very
important H and um yeah just to say this
year we had in plan to actually go ahead
with a format we use in Israel for
science communication which is called
science on the bar uh this is something
that started in Tel Aviv H where um
scientists actually in in Israel
scientists as part of their scientific
education are also taught scientific
communication to speak about their
research to the general public in terms
that can be H understood and that arouse
curiosity and uh and engagement and uh
so scientists come in these in Israel on
in in the framework of this event of
science on the bar they come to bars and
people just come and have a drink and
listen to them talking about their
research and we were going to do that
this year
um with a few Duos of Israeli and German
scientists to speak about their um their
joint work in Quantum around censoring
and also uh with Marine research um the
events in Israel now uh had us cancel
three out of four of the events uh the
remaining one will still take place uh
because the scientists couldn't leave
their families in Cal or and other
difficulties but hopefully and next year
we will be already in a a in a good
stable situation again and we will be
able to uh um to uh bring our plans back
again to uh make them happen and then
you are all invited to come in here
looking forward to it thank
you and this is also very good as a
concluding Mark the promise of
participating build science week 24 as
well that's very good
I would like to ask as one last uh round
of like what would you like the audience
like take home message like from this
discussion maybe starting
here okay then there there's one
question okay well let's see okay one
more question we can
do okay but do you really think it's
enough because I mean we have
governments who are um who are paying
more money for weapons and War than they
pay for Education we have
governments who um are more interested
to make their politic by feelings and by
hate than giving good Solutions what I
realized in the last couple of weeks is
that science actually gives us a lot of
answers to problems we're facing but
nowadays politicians are not really
interested in use those Solutions but
rather go with um um let's say not so
good Solutions like in Berlin for
example that we stopped every uh bicycle
lane just for having more um space for
cars which is I don't know if that's a
really good thing so what can science do
what can scient uh scientific
collaboration do to make sure that
politicians listen more to um Solutions
of problems um
yeah they've already found
yeah well probably Ina chor wants to
answer this one but just just one just
one little remark um my experience in
talking to politicians is not that they
are themselves not curious and not
willing to to to listen to scientific
explanation to
issues we're still a democracy right so
they have to listen to the people right
so and if we are not able to bring the
insights that science provides via
adequate science communication and
education to a very broad audience it's
not only the responsibility of the
politicians to to do the right thing but
it's also the responsibility of all us
the people to take a couple of minutes
every day I don't know and to maybe read
into something or inform yourself about
something and keep up with new
technology keep up and
and utilize these these numerous uh
offers from from the science world that
we want to explain all the time so we're
looking for for audience to to take it
up so I would hand this question back to
you to everybody here what can I do to
to spark curiosity what can I do when
was the last time I read through some
article about something I did not know
yet right when did I take my time not
scrolling through social media pictures
but maybe reading a little more in depth
into I don't know what right some some
some nature phenomenon okay but I'm
pretty sure you want to talk as the
politician
here yes um um there are lots of
solutions in science that's clear but
maybe we have um sometimes um the
solutions are a bit isolated we need
more um trans um
disciplinary um Solutions I think we we
have to think political Solutions
broader than only and Technical
Solutions we have to think about Finance
we have to think about how could
Solutions be accepted um how we take all
the people with us on the way to to
realize these Solutions and bring them
on the streets and maybe um that's um
there we have two
um um our thinking is not
um um transdisciplinary enough um
between politics and science um to to
bring these Solutions into reality and
um so we have um I thinking of um
um uh as an one example where the
solution is only technical but not um uh
it was not um enough thought about
acceptance and how to get that
acceptance so maybe that's one answer to
your
question maybe if I can add uh there was
coid that we were dealing with a while
ago and uh this was a time uh when
actually H scientists could really H
significantly inform political political
decisions that were needed to be made in
and I think that uh H being here as a
diplomat looking at the way Germany and
Israel worked on this and both countries
leaned heavily on the scientists H there
was H at least in Israel unprecedented
cooperation between scientists and uh
Civil Service even not only politics to
uh really
make scientifically fact-based uh policy
that to the best you know we made
mistakes for sure along the way in terms
of how the governments acted and but we
tried to be as close as possible to the
facts H I think it was an important
milestone in the development of this
interface between politics government
and Science and uh I I think that uh and
also actually there was very good
exchange between Israel and Germany in
what whatever science we had in Israel
ER we helped Germany with and vice versa
the sharing of knowledge was
crucial H also across boundaries and
finally I would
say um that uh ER this the topic of
prioritizing the uh whatever resources
you have and allocating them it's not
easy but as uh referred in a
democracy ER the governments listen to
the people and so if you think that
something is not done enough and you
want more to be done you can take it on
you have
voice very nice
uh but we're still having to going to do
the round of conclusion conclusions so
and next uh okay okay uh as the Berlin
science week 2024 was already uh
advertised let me advertise another
event that would
uh would be happy to engage a lot of
scientists around the world in 2024 and
happening also in Berlin it will be
Ukraine recovery conference uh which
happens every every year in another
Capital it it used to be Ukraine reforms
conference but now uh the main I but now
it has to be trans it had to be
transformed and I guess recovery of
Ukraine will be a great common task
where science and all the knowledge of
very
different uh very
different dimensions will be will be
needed and and what I would love
to uh to to say as a conclusion make
science not
[Applause]
propaganda Pro would you like to give a
take-home message
for yes I'm every day
very okay very pleased very um I feel I
think it great uh to be um Minister for
higher education and I'm learning every
day about
Solutions um and um I wish that uh we
have a better dialogue between politics
and science um to understand each other
better often I say um the main uh
problem is um to find the right
questions before we find the right
answers and um that's my My Wish for
Science and for science
diplomacy um in Berlin and um in the
world and I hope that science can um
contribute to rebuilding cultural
heritage in Ukraine um to to heal
um the um um okay to heal something
between in in the societies between the
societies and um yes um can help um
to um to um strengthen the cultural
identities even if there were crisis
even if there was War uh especially
after war and we can contribute to to
Healing the world a bit with
science I would like to connect maybe to
what you said about the importance of
questions and to leave you all with a
question uh related to what we talked
about in terms of positive
doing H and the question would be what
can I do for each one of you for each
one of us what can I do uh that is
significant uh in relation to maybe that
we've spoken about today uh perhaps uh
write a letter to your local politician
or a state politician or a wound level
politician H or to the United Nations
perhaps about the kidnapped hostages
Israelis held by Hamas or perhaps about
science and the uh H allocated
resources ER but uh uh don't stand by
take a stand think what's important to
you feel what's right and ask yourself
what can I do today to make this world a
little better thank
[Applause]
you well my my wish for the for the
final remarks are quite easy I would
love everybody to be part of this
movement and it's very easy I will give
you a little tip what you can do once
we're done you're in one of the greatest
and most fascinating museums of this
country okay so maybe once you leave
this this panel here today go around and
look at something you have never looked
at before and talk to somebody who's
standing there that you don't know about
what you see because then you're already
first step into science diplomacy and
utilize this Museum and this Berlin
science week campus is really is
amazing
uh yeah my for my final remarks um I
think we've learned that Art and Science
um both challenge our perceptions and
push boundaries of what is known and um
so just as every brush stroke on a body
bear tells a story of unity and
friendship every scientific
collaboration reflects Humanity's shared
quest for knowledge and progress and
together
they can paint a picture of a world
where differences are celebrated and
yeah and that's why uh I would like to
um together with my with um Berlin
science week I would like to invite you
to join us tomorrow at halz Mark um for
the body bear life painting event where
we will craft a symbol of solidarity for
Ukraine and um where you can all be part
of it and uh yeah and especially we
would like to thank you also of course
um the Berlin Secretary of State for
international Affairs um Florian Howers
who supported this event and to made who
made it possible that we can yeah um do
this um together so please come and join
[Applause]
tomorrow and that was it for us um I I
think we could have talked forever about
this topic and there are many side
topics side Aven we could go to but okay
time is running and um thank you thank
you very much I think uh it went in
totally different direction as post
planning so sorry for my uh yeah um but
it was super interesting also for me to
to hear all this and I hope also for our
audiences and thank you all for the
questions and for coming here and the
Bing science week is still going on so
for another eight days so no six days
sorry um so I hope to see you all again
at different events of the Bing science
week and thank you online audiences
there are also more more online events
coming up so um hope to see you all and
thank you very much let's make this
world a better place
[Applause]
together